les plages landaises font peau neuve
avant l'été pour la première fois les
quinze communes du littoral et le
conseil général mène de front le combat
anti pollution des 106 km de côtes
tous les ans le département faisait le
ménage de printemps des plages et chaque
commune organisait selon ses ressources
l'entretien quotidien de ces parcelles
mais les plages avec green univers la
collecte va désormais être effectué
toute l'année
l'objectif donc de traiter environ en
raison d'une fois par semaine l'été
l'ensemble du littoral et de deux fois
par semaine les points les plus
fréquentés à savoir donc les plages
surveillées ce travail de fourmi des 4 à
taux de plage et sous haute surveillance
une moto équipée d'une caméra vidéo
inspectent mémorise les lieux à nettoyer
le département a investi plus de 8
millions de francs pour le matériel et
assurera son fonctionnement de 4
millions par an vingt-quatre personnes
assurent ce service très spécial de
nettoyage recrutement on a fait un
effort tout particulier vers des gens
qui soient capables de réagir notamment
avec pompons l'on trouve des produits
présumés toxiques ou des produits un
petit peu délicat à traiter donc nous
avons pris essentiellement beaucoup
d'anciens pompiers des gens aussi qui a
vu une formation militaire
en plus des jeunes de la région
contrairement à une idée reçue ce ne
sont pas les vacanciers qui sont les
principaux responsables de la pollution
des plages pollution plusieurs sources
une partie arrive de la côte espagnole
par le phénomène de courantologie une
autre partie importante également par
les courants et pleuvent cocotiers
vaincre la pollution landaise n'ira pas
cependant sans l'arrêt des déversements
espagnol